There's another way we can
build an ensemble of learners.
We can build them using
the same learning algorithm but
train each learner on
a different set of the data.
This is what's called bootstrap
aggregating or bagging.
It was invented by Bremen in
the late '80s, early '90s.
Here's how bagging works.
So what we do is we create
a number of subsets of the data.
I've drawn little bags here
to represent bags of data.
And each one of these is
a subset of the original data.
Now how do we collect these?
Well, we do it randomly.
So for this subset it
contains n prime values and
our original data set contains
n different instances.
We grab n prime of them, at random, with
replacement from this original data.
So what, with replacement means is,
let's say we had
these values, we might grab this one and
put it in our bag.
We might randomly grab this one and
put it in our bag, but each time we grab
randomly, we randomly choose across
the whole collection of data.
So we might choose this one again and
put it in the bag.
So this one and this one are really
the same one and they're repeated twice.
And that's okay.
That's what with replacement means.
So we crate all together m
of these groups or bags.
And each one of them contains n prime
different data instances chosen
at random with replacement.
Let's note these things.
So, n is the number of training
instances in our original data.
N prime is the number of instances
that we put in each bag and
m is the number of bags.
We almost always want n
prime to be less than n.
Usually about 60%.
So each of these bags has about
60% as many training instances
as our original data.
That's just a rule of thumb.
Now, we use each of these collections
of data to train a different model.
We have now m different models,
each one trained on a little
bit of different data.
And just like when we have an ensemble
of different learning algorithms,
here we have an ensemble of different
models we query in the same way.
We query each model with the same x and
we collect all of their outputs.
We take the y output of each model,
take their mean, and
boom, that's our y for the ensemble.
Now keep in mind we can
wrap this in a single API.
Just like that API you wrapped your
[INAUDIBLE] in and your KNN learner in.